in the dynamic world of modern business
where strategies evolve rapidly and
decisions are driven by data the role of
a business analyst plays a pivotal role
welcome to Simply learn and we bring you
a comprehensive Guide to Becoming a
successful business analyst today's
tutorial is based on the business
analyst roadmap for 2024 with leaving no
Stone Center we are going to take a deep
dive into the list of skills tools and
principles that Empower you Frameworks
that guide you and programming languages
that enable you to perform and automate
critical verticals of business analysis
the best part of today's tutorial is
we'll provide insights on how to gain
Real World Experience Bridging the Gap
between theory and practice and making
you a sought after asset in the job
market so join us as we get started on
this thrilling adventure where you'll
not only navigate the business analyst
roadmap but also learn how to steer your
career towards unparalleled Heights
ready to conquer the world of business
analysis let's Sail on this journey
together with that said if these are the
type of videos you would like to watch
then hit that like button and subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
whenever we drop a new video also if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply don't suppose
graduate program in business analysis
from Purdue University in collaboration
with Amazon Google and Microsoft should
be your go to option for more details
use the link mentioned in the
description box below also if you are
new to business analysis and want to
upgrade your skill to become a
successful business analyst with proper
training and certification from experts
then we would recommend you to proceed
with a business analysis Masters program
that will not only help you with
fundamentals but also take you through
the real-time Capstone projects to
strengthen your learnings to match the
industry standards for for more details
use the link mentioned in the
description box below now without any
further delay over to our training
experts so now let's get started with
the business analyst roadmap for 2024.
we will get started with understanding
who is a business analyst followed by
that we will go through the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
next ahead we have the list of skills
you need to become a successful business
analyst with that discussed we will
proceed with the top company's hiring
business analyst along with their salary
compensations being offered we will be
wrapping up the video by discussing the
most important part of today's session
that is about the process of becoming a
professional business analyst in 2024. I
hope I made myself play every agenda so
make sure to stick to the end of this
session so that you don't miss out on
any of the perks of this session so
first let's get started with
understanding who is a business analyst
a business analyst here is the
professional who assesses the
organization's business needs identifies
opportunities for improvement and
provides later driven recommendations to
facilitate and formed decision making
and enhance operational efficiency to
simplify it a business analyst is
someone who helps a company figure out
how to make things work better and
smarter they use data and Analysis to
provide suggestions for making the
business run more efficiently now moving
further into the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here are some of the top roles and
first understanding business needs
business analysts work closely with
stakeholders to understand the
organization's objectives challenges and
needs they identify opportunities for
improvement and Define perfect project
goals next requirement Gathering the
collect and document detailed
requirements from various stakeholders
including end users to ensure that
projects align with business objectives
the third one data analysis business
analysts analyze data to identify Trends
patterns and insights that can inform
decision making they may use statistical
tools and techniques to interpret data
are the fourth role and responsibility
is about project process mapping let
document and analyze existing business
processes identifying bottlenecks and
areas for optimization they also design
and purpose new processes where needed
now getting into the fifth one that is
about solution design business analysts
collaborate with technical teams Traders
and solutions that meet business
requirements they may create functional
specifications and system design
documents next ahead is communication
effective communication is the key
business analyst facilitate
communication between business
stakeholders and Technical teams
ensuring that everyone is on the same
page moving ahead we have testing and
quality assurance they often participate
in testing activities to verify that
Solutions meet requirements and are free
of Defense next ahead we have change
management business analysts help manage
the changes associated with implementing
new processes or systems ensuring a
smooth transition and user adoption and
next ahead we have documentation that
maintain comprehensive documentation
including requirements process flows and
project plans to provide a clear record
of project activities the 10th rule is
project management some business
analysts may take on project management
responsibilities ensuring that projects
are delivered on time within the budget
next the 11th one is training and
support they may provide training to end
users on new systems or processes and
often ongoing spot and troubleshooting
and lastly 12th one continuous
Improvement business analysts promote
the culture of continuous to monitor the
impact of implemented Solutions and
identifying further optimization
opportunities these roles and
responsibilities can vary depending on
the organization and the specific
project business analyst play a crucial
role in Bridging the Gap between
business needs and Technical Solutions
ultimately contributing to the success
and efficiency of the organization
moving ahead we shall get into the
skills required to become a successful
professional business analyst in 2024.
business analysts require a combination
of Technical and non-technical skills to
excel in their roles here are some
important technical skills for a
business analyst first one data analysis
business analysts should be proficient
in data analysis techniques including
data mining data modeling and
statistical analysis tools like Excel
SQL and data visualization software for
example you have the power bi are often
used next skill is requirements
Gathering familiarity with requirement
management tools and methodologies is
essential tools like Microsoft Visio
jira or specialized requirement
management software help in documenting
and tracking requirements moving ahead
we have a process modeling knowledge of
process modeling techniques and tools
such as BPM and that is business process
model and notation helps in visualizing
and documenting business processes
fourth one is database skills Basics
database skills including the ability to
write SQL queries and understand
database structures are valuable for
accessing and analyzing data the fifth
skill is about the programming languages
while not always required Proficiency in
programming languages like python or R
can be advantageous especially for
handling and analyzing large data sets
all automating some redundant tasks now
the sixth skill is business intelligent
tools understanding how to use Pi tools
or business intelligence tools can Aid
in data visualization and Reporting
tools like Tableau power bi or click
wave are commonly used proceeding ahead
we have seventh skill that is about
project management tools familiarity
with project management tools like
Microsoft Project or agile project
management software and the very
beneficial especially when managing
project timelines and tasks the eighth
skill is about data warehousing
knowledge of data warehousing Concepts
and tools can help business analysts
work with large data sets efficiently
moving ahead we have the ninth skill
which is about the Erp systems
understanding Erp or enterprise resource
planning systems like sap or Oracle or
Salesforce can be valuable when
analyzing data and requirements in
organizations that use these systems the
10th skill is about Version Control
proficiency inversion control systems
like it can be beneficial when
collaborating on the documentation or
working in development Fields now next
ahead is business and process automation
familiarity with automation tools and
techniques can be useful for identifying
opportunities to streamline processes
and improve efficiency now the 12th one
software development life cycle or sdlc
an understanding of stlc methodologies
example agile waterfall is crucial for
aligning business requirements with
development processes remember that the
specific technical skills required can
vary depending on the industry and
organization being adaptable and willing
to learn new tools and Technologies is
also an important skill for a business
analyst as the field continues to evolve
now proceeding ahead we will discuss the
company's hiring business analyst here
are the name of the top 10 companies
known for hiring business analysts also
there are number of companies entire one
try to entirely and also some startup
companies which are actively looking for
certified and professional business
analysis so before that let's discuss
the top big players in the industry they
are Deloitte Accenture IBM vacancy and
Company Amazon Microsoft Google JP
Morgan Chase and go Facebook all meta
and Oracle now proceeding ahead we will
discuss the salary compensation being
offered by these companies so basically
we are looking at the highest average
salary being offered to business
analysts so when it comes to India an
entry-level business analyst in India
can expect an annual salary ranging from
3 lakhs to 6 lakhs or more depending on
the factors that are based on the
company and location you're working with
next if you are an intermediate
candidate three to four years of
experience then you can expect a salary
of six to 12 lakhs and if you are a
highly experienced person that is more
than four to five years of experience
and you can expect the salary numbers
ranging from 12 to 20 lakhs per annum
and in USA a beginner level of business
analyst can expect an annual salary of
fifty thousand dollars to eighty
thousand dollars per annum if you are an
intermediate candidate that has two to
three years of experience then you can
expect eighty thousand dollars to 120
000 per annum and if you are a highly
experienced candidate that is with
experience of more than four or five
years of experience then you can expect
around 120 000 to 160 000 per hour based
on the company you're working with and
the location is working here now
presenting ahead we have the point which
is is the most important for today's
discussion that is how to become a
business analyst discovering the path to
becoming a proficient business analyst
involves a series of strategic steps the
first one has Define your objective
start by gaining a deep understanding of
the role and responsibilities of a
business analyst explore blogs and
online courses to clarify your goals and
interests in this field the next step is
Education Foundation typically a
bachelor's degree in the initial
requirement for an incredible business
and a position pursuing Advanced degrees
such as Masters can significantly
enhance your prospects in this
competitive field moving ahead we have
sharpened your skills as the next step I
feel to develop specific skills the top
5 essential skills include Proficiency
in business analytics problem solving
capabilities effective communication
stakeholder analysis and Technical
expertise communication skills in
particular play a pivotal role as
businessman is Rich the gap between the
various teams and stakeholders followed
by Resident you have the certification
earning online business and the
certifications can validate your
competencies and keep you updated with
the latest tools and Technologies while
not always mandatory certifications can
set you apart in your job market and
open doors for career next gain Real
World Experience practical experience is
invaluable engage in real world business
analytics projects to apply your
knowledge and grasp the Practical
aspects of the production this hands-on
experience will not only roster your
skill set but also deepen your
understanding of business operations now
the next one is the portfolio build your
own portfolio create a comprehensive
portfolio showcasing your practical
projects assignments internships and
certifications this portfolio serves as
a testament to your capabilities and can
significantly impact your job prospects
next ahead we have the job application
once you've acquired the necessary
training and experience it's time to
apply for business analyst positions
tailor your resume to highlight your
achievements and skills making a strong
first impression research and
cooperation is the next step prior to
applying research prospective employers
and their specific requirements tailor
your application and interview
preparation accordingly demonstrating
your commitment and knowledge for the
business and its needs so these were the
important steps to become a business
analyst Now by following these steps you
will be well equipped to embark on a
fulfilling career as a business analyst
whether you are aiming to start as a
junior business analyst or aspire to
higher positions continuous learning and
practical experience are your key to
success feeling inspired already
consider checking the simply learns
postgraduate program in business
analytics from Purdue University that is
being offered in collaboration with
Amazon Google and Microsoft for more
details use the link in the description
box below this link should redirect you
to to the official course landing page
that will give you a complete overview
of the course being offered should you
need any assistance PPT project code and
other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
be happy to help you as soon as possible
until next time thank you and keep
learning stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you